[Música]
los habitantes de Nueva caledonia la
llaman la laguna
estas infinitas tonalidades de azul
cubren unos 24.000 kilómetros cuadrados
y están declaradas patrimonio de la
humanidad por la UNESCO rodeada por una
barrera de coral de 1600 kilómetros es
la laguna más grande del mundo
cada fin de semana este velero navega a
estas pequeñas Islas Léelo amedi es
famoso por su emblemático faro está a
sólo 40 minutos en barco de numea la
ciudad más grande de Nueva caledonia
[Música]
primeras impresiones magnífico parece
una piscina es increíble Es como estar
en el paraíso
La Isla es uno de los destinos más
populares de la laguna la gente viene
aquí a pasar el día con amigos y
familiares
esa es una de las diferencias con la
Francia continental cogemos un barco y
en 30 minutos estamos en una isla
estamos de vacaciones Aunque solo
tengamos un día libre en el trabajo
cuando venimos aquí nos sentimos
completamente desconectados Por qué
bueno el agua turquesa Es tranquila no
hay ruido los pájaros cantan También
tenemos la suerte de ver tortugas cuando
llegué al muelle ya había visto tres
tortugas simplemente increíble
El guardián del faro es la única persona
que vive en la isla Este joven de 23
años ha pasado los últimos dos años
viviendo aquí con esta impresionante
vista
pasa tres semanas en la isla y tiene
tres días para descansar en numea
trabajo bajo el sol Así que está bien el
tiempo siempre es estupendo y aquí
tienes todo lo que necesitas y a veces
no se siente solo a veces sí quiero ver
a mi familia por lo demás está bien
estas Islas se parecen a la Polinesia
francesa su prima del Pacífico
este hotel cuenta con 64 habitaciones 25
de ellas sobre pilotes se encuentra a
pocos kilómetros de nomea y esta pareja
acaba de casarse
Y ayer Así que en la víspera de nuestra
boda llegamos aquí al bungalú y a las
tres y media de la mañana vimos un
delfín probablemente estaba cazando Así
que eso fue un extra
desde la suspensión de las restricciones
Kobe 19 este hotel de cuatro estrellas
también ha visto regresar a su clientela
internacional
en particular turistas de las vecinas
Australia y Nueva Zelanda la laguna
sigue siendo muy atractiva y los
turistas me dicen que en su país no
tienen esto tienen mares Azules y
grandes olas pero nada como aquí con las
características únicas de la laguna y
siempre les atrae ver las tortugas el
agua turquesa nos hemos convertido en
Víctimas de nuestro propio éxito y está
a tope de su capacidad ahora mismo
estamos llenos
el turismo solo representa el 5% del
producto interno bruto de Nueva
caledonia dos veces menos que en la
Francia continental dado el tamaño del
territorio y sus parajes naturales
únicos las autoridades locales quieren
seguir desarrollando la industria sin
embargo este desarrollo debe ser
sostenible ya que la laguna está
catalogada y permanece bajo alta
vigilancia
cada mañana estos guardacostas patrullan
el mar lucha contra la pesca ilegal los
vertidos al mar están atentos a todas
estas infracciones
tienen capitán ustedes la capitana bueno
no la conozco estas personas están con
usted sí pero los estoy supervisando Ok
gracias
que tenga un buen día
Hace unos días el equipo acompañado por
agentes de la policía local detuvo a un
hombre que fue sorprendido pescando
tortugas la persona fue interrogada se
le incautaron el coche y la embarcación
se ha fijado una fecha para que
comparezca ante el tribunal a principios
del próximo año La persona se arriesga a
una multa de hasta 15.000 euros y no se
le devolverá el coche ni la embarcación
el año pasado Se realizaron unos Diez
mil controles con solo 150 detenciones
un reflejo de lo comprometidos que están
los habitantes de la nueva caledonia con
la conservación de la Laguna
[Música]